we hear about the 24-hour news cycle all
the time the reality is due to our
fast-paced lives and ever splintering
attention span stories really only stay
in the news for about 24 hours and when
stories do stick around for more than
that the cable news shows an online
outlets feel the need to deliver us the
news in the fastest flashiest and often
sloppiest fashion possible in the
political world this need for excitement
leads us going from scandal to scandal
or he-said she-said instead of focusing
on the real issues that affect our
everyday lives
I mentioned this never-ending matrix of
information because I find along the way
instead of talking about the right
things our national conversation almost
always talks about the wrong things we
debate whether Trump's wall is racist
rather than discussing whether a nation
should protect its borders as it sees
fit we talk about a $15 minimum wage
without questioning whether it will lead
to McDonald's replacing all its
employees with iPads we argue about
income inequality without really taking
the time to think about what the role of
government should be on top of all this
then we get our news from a pundit class
filled with former politicians and
campaign people who pretend to be
neutral when they usually couldn't be
anything further from it of course in
this election the pundits almost all
predicted everything wrong the whole
time especially on the Republican side
but for some reason we still turn to
them to predict how the future of
America will play out when you add up
the fast news cycle with the network's
who just want views and online creators
who just want clicks you get exactly
what we're left with right now a whole
lot of noise often it's seemingly
impossible to figure out what is true or
even who is trying to tell you the truth
throw in an American education system
which has been co-opted by safe spaces
and trigger warnings instead of critical
thinking and you have a toxic mess
designed to cater to the simplest and
worst parts of ourselves the more you
scream bloviate and demonize the more it
somehow seems you are right righteous
indignation has become the new
Ruth but actually it's just a bunch of
[ __ ] which is why on the Rubin
report I try to focus on big ideas and
not get bogged down in the daily grind
of nonsensical news stories or the
endless horse race of the political
season my guest this week is your on
Brook the president and executive
director of the iron Rand Institute just
by saying the name I ran there I know
some people's heads will explode I was
an author and phosphor best known for
her books The Fountainhead and Atlas
Shrugged she created the philosophy
known as objectivism which she described
as quote the concept of man as a heroic
being with his own happiness as the
moral purpose for his life with
productive achievement as his noblest
activity and reason as his only absolute
ina and her work are revered by many
people on the right and despised by many
people on the left people on the right
tend to love her emphasis on the
individual while people on the Left tend
to revile her dismissal of the
collective so much of what's happening
in the country right now from the Bernie
Revolution to the social justice warrior
movement to the rise of Trump can be
explained or at the very least discussed
within the prism of Objectivism I'm
gonna dive deep into it with Joran and
see if we can come up with some answers
to solve some of the problems of today
what is man's highest pursuit what is
the role of government can we live for
ourselves and still help others these
are just a couple of the questions that
I want to get into whether you agree or
disagree with all the answers that
you'll hear is largely irrelevant we
need to discuss big issues so that our
conversations aren't dominated by little
minds
you